some developing news this morning a huge
fire
early this morning up in the far
northwest valley flames
shot from a condominium project now
under construction at least it was
now investigators are trying to figure
out what started that fire
we have hector mejia live at the senior
sky point and tanea with the latest
hector good morning
good morning john and with daylight
hours we're getting a better look at the
damage that's left behind just take a
look out here these condos now
considered destroyed and it could take
several days for investigators to
determine
what started this fire as many as 65
firefighters battled large flames out
here overnight
and roads were closed at one point the
good news though is that no one was hurt
the orange glow and the smoke could be
seen for several miles earlier this
morning
this is a winslow condo community near
sky point antonia in the far northwest
valley
multiple condos that were in the framing
stages of construction
caught fire for some reason las vegas
firefighters say it started just after
midnight
and the first arriving units found
massive flames shooting from this
construction project and the damages
are estimated at well over half a
million dollars and we were also told
that investigators were worried about
the building possibly collapsing so they
were not able to finish their
investigation overnight
and they are coming at some point this
morning to begin looking into what
started this fire
in the first place reporting live this
morning in the northwest valley hector
mejia
8 news now